hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to nether this is a game
that's kind of in the same vein as dayz
and that it's an apocalyptic survival
game on servers where you play with
other people and I'm pretty sure that
they can kill me now if you know me I
play dayz awhile ago and I didn't
exactly like it but a lot of you guys
liked watching it so I'm gonna give this
one a try and there doesn't seem to be
an option for a big thing mustache so
I'm just gonna guess that I'm gonna have
to do without
let's get black so that no one else can
see me and hopefully I'll be able to
hide a little bit at least there's
literally like two options here okay
alright let's just all right fine you
know what it's fine I don't have any
experience I don't have any levels so
let's just get into it
oh hello oh my oh well I guess I seem to
be just in the game okay so like in dayz
I imagine that it's a gigantic map now I
don't know much about this game in
particular but I imagine it's a giant
map with a lot of people and you can
find items in it you seem to have a
knife stamina bar water compass all the
basic necessities in a zombie
apocalyptic survival now from what I saw
this actually looked like a very
interesting and well made game and from
what I see now it's not too shabby
but I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get shot
in the head by some other player because
that's how I died dayz a lot oh just
look at this kind of makes me nervous
because I I originally approached dayz
is like Oh finally someone made a gritty
realistic zombie survival but I didn't
like the other player aspect of it
I don't play a lot of competitive
multiplayer games and when people seem
to get their hands on these type of
games they tend to go ballistic and
shoot everyone on site what is this 50
Cal ammo I don't exactly have a 50 Cal
gun do I have a 50 Cal knife if I hit
the back of the bullets with my knife
will it shoot someone or is Dombey
well they definitely got the feeling of
loneliness downright because I don't see
anyone or anything okay so someone's
gonna shoot me in the face I know it
okay
save some why excuse me what did I do
now
I secured a safe zone but what does that
even mean well I guess it killed all the
zombies do I have a flashlight or
anything at all no looks like a lot of
these buildings have boarded up so I'm
gonna have to go into the ones that are
already broken down maybe this one hello
another surge is underway ooh I got a
Smith & risley what is that 9-millimeter
ammo I got a gun I guess that's a little
bit better
Smith & risley I'm guessing that you're
hilarious interpretation of gun brands
that you can't use because of copyright
and whatnot cash cash cash I have no
idea is there gonna be like a store or
something I gotta say this game looks
pretty fantastic I believe it's made on
the Unreal Engine I don't want to get to
narrator and do this I'm actually kind
of concerned because I haven't seen a
single zombie and in dayz it was like
zombies everywhere you could barely walk
four zombies
hot damn that is an awesome-looking
sport okay is that my sword no that's
the kitchen knife there we go okay so
now I got a bolo sward
I don't know if that's amazing but it
looks kind of Awesome okay take this
nice and slowly like a shadow in the
night moving across the streets of this
decrepit City trying to make my way into
somewhere I don't know maybe find some
other human or not because they'd
probably shoot me in the face huh see a
lot of dayz oh um there's another Smith
and Rossi a lot of dayz
was all about the exploration in this
kind of empty world except in that world
there was a little
populated I don't know what the nether
rift whatever thing was but I'm assuming
that it's gonna be bad news
until I know better I'm just gonna keep
going in here trying to find supplies
because I was trying to play seven days
to die with Wade last night but it
wasn't working out too well I couldn't
seem to get it to function we're gonna
try again later today but that was sort
of another apocalyptic survival game
without more on the crafting of it I
think this one's just kind of gritty
nothingness I don't know how big this
map is now in the dayz version I keep I
keep harkening back to Daisy but it's
the only other comparison I can draw a
to right now it seemed to me that the
map was like I don't know fifty
kilometers in across and up or fifty by
fifty I'm not sure exactly how big so
this might be equally as big that wasn't
exactly an option to pick a map and I am
playing with other people I know this
because the server I picked was not
exactly empty Oh what is that whoa I
found out gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
it
I want this shotty alright sweet is do I
have any ammo for that I don't think so
ranged sidearm okay I do what was that I
heard some
I hear some blue I hear okay all right
and I searched through any objects or
everything gonna be on the ground I'm
guessing I kind of nails down the sense
of helplessness I suppose take walk and
climb up one yeah where am I going what
am i doing I don't even know what is
that sound I need to be concerned hey
I'm gonna need some water cuz I see a
little water bar down on the bottom
right what is that what is that what is
that lights humming there are other
people over there Kyle like barricades
set up on guessing when they're trying
to hold off the zombie infestation but
judging by this overgrowth I mean this
had to be here like five ten years after
the apocalypse I'm actually kind of
nervous I'm actually surprised I mean
for one I get always angsty when I'm or
not angsty that's emo well I get anxious
when I'm playing a multiplayer games you
know that that feeling you get probably
some of you can relate that your heart
rate picks up and you get the sense of
nervousness when you know you're like on
display and there are other people that
could kill you at any moment
it's just a trap
pills pain pills okay got it good got it
who's that
I heard that sound of crow okay like a
little on edge on edge
okay let's try to relax a little bit I
don't think I think I'm jumping at
shadows here I don't think there's
actually anything out here from what I
saw it was like there was nothing but
zombies in the screenshots damn hearing
that more and more nothing what's going
on did I just find a server with no
zombies in it okay it disappeared into
the ground Oh
Reaper is leading a surge know what that
means I don't know what Reapers are
except in Mass Effect but they were kind
of big so I think we'd have bigger
problems in zombies at that point okay
they kind of created zombies with the
husks okay
I need more ammo apparently thought I
was good on finding supplies but
apparently I was very wrong
who did they even come from they just
appeared out of nowhere
oh oh noises noises okay I'm gonna
assume that the noises I was hearing
actually meant something and I need to
be worried okay that sounds like a crow
but then again I've been wrong before
now I've got the high ground which
hopefully should mean that I can get
this places flip picking huge are you
seeing this can I go in those
skyscrapers over there
holy hell this place is gigantic oh man
this is actually really cool I mean this
is rather interesting I have to stay I
just know I'm gonna die soon but I have
a thousand health I don't know if that's
I don't know if like I don't know
anything I don't know
I don't know if that's normal I don't
know if I'm weird I don't know if I'm
doing something wrong right I'm a total
noob at this game so forgive me if
you've been playing a while and although
I don't think this game has been out a
while but if you've been playing and
experiencing it better than I have then
hi I'm more power to you so only scrub
it okay it's awfully pretty
look at the sky is beautiful actually it
is kind of pretty in a sort of oh man
you think there are people up there
what's with the flash ease it is a sort
of very very pretty setting I mean I
kind of like the sort of desolation
feeling of it probably bad idea I heard
that hey all right
I'm gonna do something I see you can't
get me I'm up here you're down there all
right let's go ah you can't get me huh
where'd you go leveling up like a mother
humper that's good I guess I'm running
out of ammo though how do I crouch can i
I'm stuck okay there we go
he's got a void the somme toms I'm gonna
assume that those are very low-level
creatures and I shouldn't be too sure
myself because I'm probably gonna die
okay they're tense in here where some
sort of survival outpost was I guess I
don't found an item in a what was it
over there done item item item item item
item item no and I haven't found an item
in forever okay whatever whatever
whatever I just got to get going cuz it
seems and I'm in trouble
I don't even know how I would run into
another player in here but then again I
ran into other players in dayz and I was
on servers with only like two people in
them I swear my heart has been pounding
this entire time I've been playing as I
apologize if I'm being very skittish but
I'm not I made it but wait a minute that
is not the same place that has hanging
Stelling tense and not good side there's
stuff here bando jazz crunchy bends all
right mistake kid all right and IFIF my
inventory is getting full or what what
is it
I saw something here was that some sort
of campfire there's another player here
or is that just a thing bad idea to have
a fire in the middle of a building but
whatever I won't judge doing that to me
Jesus you're just a little one
there we go and I like looting no okay
all right it's got to become these keep
freaking me out cuz they appear out of
nowhere yeah very stressful game player
normally so if you could back off it'd
be lovely I've only got five shots left
I need something something there's just
nothing here oh there's just nothing
here and those aren't even the worst of
the zombies I think those are just like
the imps of the zombie world like barely
even a little bit good come on baby come
on baby tell me some good tell me
something good nothing I must be in a
bad segment of town or something because
I am not finding anything I'm all out of
stamina I need to stop sprinting so much
a guest not even getting any stamina oh
I have to stop completely to get stamina
back that's weird no
okay it kind of comes back if I don't
deplete it completely so I just need to
be very careful is it just me or is the
day/night cycle being completely Wonka
fide what is going on or maybe I was
just going in between buildings and the
shadows actually work really well I'm
gonna guess the latter because this game
is rather well put together a little bit
okay there's a little does that mean
does that mean what is that a baseball
bat I don't think I need that I have a
bolo knife I'm gonna assume that's
better than a bolo sward that's better
hey I see you ah you didn't sneak up on
me this time I see you I don't need to
kill you so I'm not gonna I don't have
enough ammo to take you on oh no you
back off back off you ugly mother hopper
you stupid ass shooting smoke spewing
piece of crap you stay back there I
swear to god that's what we did Oh No
okay I must in the running cream I know
it running creates noise and I'll do bad
coming not gonna give me I'm Way up here
it gets away down there I can't give me
it can't give me ah it's just a whole
lot of nothing
is a new sound Oh what are you I'm
saving my bullets for you whatever you
are don't like you God what the hell
you disappear under the ground does that
even mean
leaps my duo hi hi there Oh someone's
gonna sneak up on you with a bolo sward
I probably should have been using this
friend of getting him wasting my ammo
I'll run it away finally found a prey
you can't pray on I was like the name of
this game was like prayer pray oh please
don't find me even now I'm the hunter
maybe I don't know I'm leveling up quite
quickly what excuse me see ya hole do
you do exam two what oh well hey what
hey stop that
don't dick with me oh this burg has
world-class museums now they're just
tough old buildings that will stand up
to anything okay well do you do exam
well do you examine why damn it boy it
didn't let me exam I was holding it
didn't do nothin oh man okay aha final
seven what do you mean no bag space oh I
have another gun okay let me dump let me
dump this gun no he dropped how do I
drop how do i okay there we go drop
oh [ __ ] unloaded it there was uh
whatever you know what I don't have time
to waste let me eat my crunchy doodads
crunchy wait no uh hold it down you got
to hold down everything to get this okay
okay
yeah and I'm surprised that these trucks
are still working
I gotta admit this game is really cool
like no joke it's actually really cool
I mean there is kind of the lack of
panic from sheer number of zombies but I
mean the fact that they appear out of
nowhere but they don't really I learned
they don't peer out of nowhere I just
need to not be so loud and sprint
through the city okay so anyway I think
I'm all out of time for this part here
but this game I actually really like it
it it's it's not bad I'm sure I'll
change my mind once I start running into
other know other people but for now it
ain't bad it's actually pretty fun wait
how did I oh I fell off the building
that's how I lost all that help okay
there we go
it's not bad at all I'm gonna keep
giving it a few more tries and there's
another shotgun I don't know if I have
to yeah okay let me uh if I unload that
Boosh and then drop this
I'll have shotgun AMRO sweet okay there
we go got it nailed it I'm think I'm
getting this game so anyway I'm gonna
cut it here and continue this in a few
more parts let me know if you want to
see more I'll link to the game is in the
description below once again it's kind
of a pricey game but hey this seems to
be a lot here now not all I'll need to
figure out as if it's a deeper game like
there's more substance to it so anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
games base with more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]
inside the building
against the light
the water tower we got circled back at
the water tower the Fed will have only
one location to go back you [ __ ]
I'm the greatest son a player to ever
play Thunder so you back off you [ __ ]
don't you know who I am